welcome to Istanbul a new international
hub of health tourism many of the new
visitors are from the United Arab
Emirates and Saudi Arabia these two men
are from Dubai but they're not here for
dental work an organ transplant or a nip
and tuck what they want is hair facial
hair
I'm not that was easy Anna Quindlen
Deanna muscle apology ahmed Awad and
Bassam al-qahtani feel follically
challenged that makes it tough to get a
head back in Dubai where a full beard is
a status symbol their plight prompted
them to book a transplant tour package
in Turkey one of many deals that cover
flights surgery and accommodation we saw
a report in a magazine about beard
transplants in Istanbul we'd never heard
about that before
after some friends said they were happy
with the surgery that they'd had we
wanted to do it too Nissan tashi is an
upscale neighborhood in Istanbul and
home to many fashion trends including
cosmetic surgery the array of specialist
doctors here offer everything from
breast enhancement to liposuction and
more recently facial hair transplants
the first step for the two visitors from
Dubai is a preliminary checkup bossom al
Kitani shows the doctor the kind of
beard type he's after on his smartphone
he already has facial hair but in his
opinion it's just not manly enough
having a beard in the Gulf is crucial
there are too many patches in my beard
and I want to have them filled in with
new hair Camile Helen and Devadas are
avati removes you differently the doctor
maps out his plan a bit more hair for
the cheeks and above the upper lip and
most importantly the chin area
pensive Olga's and then colleges will
take hair from the back of his head we
really won't notice it because it's so
thick there and because the hair has
very fine roots it's great for
transplanting as a beard shut up yep it
does they can miss it
sporting a full beard and whiskers is
also a big deal among native men in
Turkey mustaches are an entire culture
to themselves here we must - makes you
more of a man video parlor
there are thin long ones in the middle I
like that a lot such a milk cheetah sure
I don't have any hair on my head now so
I compensate with my beard search me
it suits some men but not all some men
grow hair in places where you don't need
it Allah God one of the men and women to
look different to each other so it's a
command from God the booming beard
business also involves barbers of course
and just as with other aspects of the
fashion world says this expert the media
exert a major influence on trimming
trends we're now seeing more young men
growing beards to this trend probably
has something to do with the highly
rated TV shows that are on right now
about the Ottoman hero
while conventional tourists check out
the Bosphorus or the Blue Mosque bossom
al Kitani is still in the clinic getting
his bandages removed the transplant took
eight hours he now has a few thousand
hairs fewer on the back of his head but
has gained a new beard he'll be able to
shave it in just two weeks time assures
the doctor but that's the last thing
this patient is planning to see how many
the surgery went well the result is just
what I was hoping for
she'd done cohesin he reckons it's a
sight to behold then he heads off with
his friend to see some traditional
sights their first stop is the famous
topkapi palace which features a hair
from the beard of Mohammed